[Inaudible] the thing that I, you know,
I try to explain to people is fame is a hack
for time. Fame is a hack for time.
If I have to sit up here and explain to you, well, I know this woman,
she's a very good person. She's very beautiful.
She's married to a hip hop person. Uh she's you know, good entrepreneurs.
If I could just say Kardashians, you know exactly what I'm talking about.
It took me three seconds and then I can move on with the conversation.
So being well known in, in an economy,
that's where basically time and attention are the biggest commodity,
like the most precious thing of money. There's a lot of money.
You can get it to a half. The time you got tons of money,
even rich people though are time poor.
The richest people in the world are some of the most time poor. And so if you,
you have to deal with that condition of the digital civilization you live in,
and fame is just a hack for time.
So I can now say gang gang on a subway,
and everybody knows what I'm talking about. And that's for me useful. Um,
the more people who know about you,
the easier my job is because I'm trying to promote positive solutions.
And yet there's this, you know, worship of attention and celebrity,
and also an understandable fear of it because it can be corrupting.
It can be isolating. It does make, you know, my life. It's very different.
Now that I'm a relatively well-known person,
at least among news nerds than it was before. Um, you know, uh,
and so yes, it, it, it there's a danger there,
but the bigger danger is that people with great ideas never get heard because we
are only willing to speak, you know,
to our own small Twitter followings and in our own Facebook groups.
And we're just afraid to walk on that big stage. And I think that, Hey, listen,
if you create a situation where there's some, you know, younger, fresher,
more edgy, less, you know, CNN ready voices,
but are still in harmony, then the movement continues to grow.
Even if some people are more disaffected with you,
but like other people who are like you, who are just maybe a little bit more,
you know, um, you know, grassroots. Uh, but listen,
I don't think that people like you can afford to keep your light under a
bushel.